who are you protecting right now so are
you protecting
this is portland in oregon on the west
coast of america
where protesters have been on the
streets for months
here's why the unrest there matters
the portland protests originally began
against police brutality and racism
every revolution in this country
has been built on the backs of black
women
one of many black lives matter protests
across the states
after months of demonstrations the
number of protesters had dwindled to
100 or so then donald trump sent in
federal officers or federal law
enforcement that i can tell you in
portland
they've done a fantastic job
they are essentially police run by the
u.s government
rather than individual states
i actually want to see this it was a
controversial move that many saw
as unconstitutional even the mayor of
portland
has said the officers aren't welcome we
have
federal officers on our streets further
escalating tensions
and causing harm to portlanders right
now the fed's being here is ridiculous
we need to make a stand
and show this not allowed in our town
things turned ugly dozens of them have
just come out
and thrown tear gas at a crowd
that on the whole were relatively
peaceful before this happened
a small group of the demonstrators had
turned violent the officers sent to
protect
government buildings started firing tear
gas and rubber bullets at the mostly
peaceful protesters
their arrival prompted thousands of
people to join the protests
i'm ashamed of the feds coming in they
don't belong here they spread across the
country
new york and chicago and philadelphia
detroit and baltimore
oakland is a mess over in washington
donald trump was using the unrest
to boost his presidential campaign this
bloodshed
must end this bloodshed will end today
i'm announcing a surge of federal law
enforcement into american
communities plagued by violent crime the
president says scenes like this
are a sign of things to come if he loses
the election in november
nobody will be safe in a biden america
but critics of the president say he's
just using the protests
to distract from coronavirus everything
is
negative don't go don't come don't do
anything
his campaign is doing badly at the
moment partly because of his response to
the pandemic
and he started saying things like this
biden wants to
defund the police leaving every citizen
at the mercy
of a socialist mob
while his agents did this wait wait what
are you doing there's liquid
you're impressing me this is what
democracy
tell me and that's why these protests
matter we're going to
defeat sleepy joe biden if president
trump can successfully argue that he can
keep america safe
he has more chance of retaining the
presidency
you